hey everybody movie retrospective time
yeah talking about brian de palma yeah
zach will be excited
[Laughter]
i tell you what i'm gonna be straight up
honest with you people [ __ ] i was
watching this movie hold on let me open
this up i was i was watching this and i
was really getting into it i was
enjoying it and i [ __ ] fell asleep i
know you were snoring i fell asleep
about halfway into it but i couldn't
help it i was [ __ ] tired and it uh it
was it shot really well this is a
gorgeous looking movie i had forgotten i
actually saw this movie uh it's called
blowout by the way it came out in 1981
i actually saw this
on cable when i was in my teens or 20s
and i remember really liking it like i
remembered um a lot of the you know
opening sequence
uh you know or the opening sequences
like the first act of the movie but i
couldn't like remember what had happened
in it so i've been wanting to like
re-watch it and i feel like it's the
movie that brian de palma made in
between
dress to kill
and scarface so scarface was after this
one of the dressed kill was before this
one and i feel like it's one that when
people talk about like the best brian de
palma movies like particularly even if
they're just talking about like his
thrillers
i kind of feel like it gets a little bit
ignored
even though i mean they just put out a
criterion collection one i think like
this year or last year or something like
that and actually i went back and there
have been like a lot of retrospective
reviews of it particularly i think last
year because it was the 40th anniversary
where a lot of critics are like
reassessing it i mean it got good
critical reviews at the time but like it
didn't really do that well at the box
office so i kind of feel like a lot of
people are reassessing it and being like
man this is like one of de palma's like
best movies and i have to say i haven't
seen all of his movies uh admittedly but
this is a damn good one it's like way
way better than i remembered yeah it's
it's a low budget movie but it's real
well crafted it's shot real well it just
goes to show you that if you give a [ __ ]
you know you're talented
you don't need any money to make a good
movie i mean 18 million that's not
nothing but yeah yeah
and the scope of the of studios that's
not that much yeah i mean it looks a lot
better than 18 million
and it's got the girl from um
it's got the girl from robocop one and
now she was actually married to brian de
palma at the time that this guy came out
yeah yeah and she plays role in there he
worked with her a lot yeah and then it's
got uh oh what's his name john travolta
probably
pre-scientology probably probably before
he was involved in something
hard to say like i said this was 81 i
don't remember when he got into it it
was later it might have been later he's
great in this and honestly i think this
is one of his best roles
he's like um it's one of his dramatic
roles you know what i mean which you
don't really see a lot maybe nowadays
you do i don't know i haven't seen like
a lot of his movies but i do kind of
feel like prior to this you know he had
been in uh
greece and he'd been in kind of like
what was the the disco movie he'd been
internet like saturday night favor he'd
been in that yeah which are good movies
i'm just saying that this is like a
little bit of a different role for him
and i thought he just like knocked it
out of the park yeah he plays a veteran
a guy who was came out of the army i
forgot what he did in the army he's like
communication because he's just like
yeah he was communications wiz he stayed
stateside and then later on he ended up
becoming a sound technician for studios
making cheap movies and he
sound records as
i guess like an assassination
assassination well at first uh well some
people it's it's an assassination
because it does feel like yeah yeah well
because what ends up happening okay so
the idea for this movie actually came
from uh there was a movie by uh
michelangelo antonioni called blow up
which was about a guy who was a fashion
photographer i think it's been a long
time since i've seen it but it was a
fashion photographer who maybe
accidentally like captured a murder like
while he was doing a fashion shoot and
then there was the other movie who was
it francis ford coppola or martin
scorsese i can't remember the
conversation that had gene hackman in it
where it was like a guy who was like uh
he bugged people and like listened and
then there was like a plot uncovered
so it's kind of like i've been wanted to
like do a review on that one too because
that one's also really good
and i think they have that on uh hbo max
actually where this one is too like if
you want to watch it it's on this movie
this movie is kind of like
what what this movie is to brian to
palma is kind of what the hand is to
oliver stone like people don't know that
the hot that the hand is oliver stone
movie but that's another kind of lower
budget real [ __ ] good movie michael
caine
but this is kind of like as good to me i
think this is kind of like the palmer's
version of like the hand a sleeper
yeah well like i said well i mean when
you bring up brian de palma everybody
talks about carrie or scarface or dress
to kill or like a lot of i mean he made
so many good movies which i guess it's
understandable but then i kind of feel
like this one gets a little bit lost in
the shuffle which like i said i guess
because he made so many good movies so
it's like easy to forget like about some
of the other ones but honestly i think
this might be
i don't know i might i haven't seen
dress to kill in a long time and i'd
kind of like want to rewatch that but
i kind of think i might like this just
as good i think this is just as good
but i don't know like i said i haven't
seen dressy kill in a long time
so yeah we were saying like nancy allen
is in this yeah she worked with him a
lot she was also in uh she was in carrie
too wasn't she and she was in like a
couple of his other movies and this also
has john lithgow in it who i think was
also in a bunch of uh a bunch of his
other movies and dennis franz who
this was pride because i feel like hill
street blues started he was in hill
street blues right and i kind of feel
like that started right around the same
time
but yeah so like i said uh this is kind
of like an amalgamation of
antonioni's blow up and the conversation
what it is is john travolta plays a guy
named jack
and he you know he has a history which
you kind of like find out about later
but he's a sound guy like a sound
designer sound technician whatever and
he works for the studio and they're
doing these really really cheesy uh you
know b horror movies
um you know some of which it's funny
because one of the movies in the movie
is called bordello of blood and i'm like
oh my god we actually have that movie
now yeah and i wondered then i wondered
if the makers like the tales from the
clip tripped bordello blood is like i
wonder if they were making direct
references i would imagine sure yeah um
but then we're in the same scene that's
what i'm saying and so i kind of feel
like the movie that he's working on at
the beginning of this movie i think it's
called co-ed frenzy now that i'm
thinking
like a porn well the [ __ ] well that's
what's funny about it is that this movie
actually opens like it's you know they
do the little logos and all that stuff
and it opens on what appears to be
a cheesy horror movie like a halloween
knockoff or something like that where
there's all these new bibles
yeah like i said so it's all these kind
of like naked women like jumping up and
down partying like in a thing while
somebody is like doing the steady cam
like outside like watching them yeah and
i am going like yeah right like that
happens girls just getting their other
ones and start dancing with each other
and i realized that oh they're [ __ ]
with us this is their [ __ ] movie yeah
well that's why i think the the
beginning of this is so brilliant
because you could be forgiven for think
because i mean uh you know de palma had
made horror movies before obviously and
he did actually start carry with that
slow motion shot like through the girls
locker room
so
you could for a second you're probably
thinking like oh is he going back to
horror oh wait this is not good like
this am i about to be like
is he like has he lost his mojo he's
trolling and then yeah so that goes on
for like three or four minutes and
you're just like oh my god this is like
a horrible and then like the funny part
comes when like there's this naked lady
in the shower and then like the the
killer comes up to her and she screams
and it is like the stupidest sounding
scream ever yeah and then they pull back
and john travolta is like that is the
worst [ __ ] scream ever so they they
established this is the guy that's
working on this movie that's doing the
sound effects and he's like we gotta
like dub over that scream because that's
ridiculous so it already pulled me in
early on
you know this is i said this is a cool
movie
and then they did a bunch of split
screen stuff that was really good yeah
he's always doing that kind of stuff
which i think is like it's really
effectively used yeah where you got a
wheel going by with a bullet going
through it and then in the foreground
you got
you got uh john travolta with his
headphones listening to it happening
like that's like what's going on yeah
and the wheels going by and you're like
oh wow that's pretty neat yeah visually
this is a gorgeous square yeah and every
time they show him like he's talking to
his
girlfriend in a damn hotel room
the establishing shots it's like these
old 80s hot 70s and 80s hotels that
would be on a damn urban exploration
video nowadays and it's still usable
it's kind of weird like going back in
time you know and then you see the front
of the hotel
the interior and the front of the car
all happening at the same time and i'm
going the palm is a [ __ ] master it's
shooting these camera angles i know i
mean anybody else just would have done a
frontal boring shot he's trying to do
shot composition and establish it the
right way so it's already early on in
the movie it's punching above its weight
i saw the beginning i saw the end and
fell asleep in the middle and then like
the movie spot it was my fault i was
tired and then by the way i see it by
the time he woke up and he was like kind
of like wait who's there that i was just
like it's too complicated
so i just i just did an analysis of the
shot competent positions and the
and the uh uh uh [ __ ] score and
everything that was going on and the
acting i could tell it was a high
quality movie i just missed the middle
part of it which is [ __ ] that's where
all the that's where all the movie
happened yeah and then i was like kind
of like because i know he has a tendency
to like fall asleep or like not pay
attention yeah and then like he wants me
to explain it and i'm just like but i'm
trying to watch it i don't want to
explain it but i was like just watch it
again or read a blog thing i'll kind of
allow me to sleep sometimes you know
work you know just does well yeah well
yeah sometimes in the evening i mean it
happens to me too and it's like i said
it's usually no ding against the movie
like oh the movie's so boring and put me
asleep no sometimes i'm just really
really tired and i want to stay awake
and watch it but i can't you know what i
mean so yeah so uh so john travolta's
character who like did i mention that
his name is jack okay his name is jack
and he works on these movies and because
they're working on this movie and the
scream is terrible this is this girl
does and they have to find another one
and then like uh the guy or the producer
the director or whatever he's just like
man we've been using like these canned
sound effects like the wind and glass
breaking and [ __ ] like that once you go
like record some new [ __ ]
so he goes out to this was all shot in
philadelphia by the way and uh he goes
out to like some bridge i'm sure it's
if you live in philadelphia you know
what bridget is but he's out there like
filming night sounds like wind and owls
and crap like that and while he's out
there filming
noise or he's not filming obviously but
he's recording noise yeah he's recording
the noise with like the big buck
yeah the shotgun mic so he's recording
all the noise and
uh he hears a car approaching and the
car actually goes like veers off the
bridge and into the creek or lake or
whatever the hell it is yeah you hear a
i guess like a tire blowout kinda yeah
hence why the movie is called blowout
yeah but there's more to it he also
realizes later on there's a shot that
somebody shot that tire out yeah
so that's the thing like so he jumps
he's like jesus christ and then like he
jumps in there and he sees that the guy
who was driving like the guy at the
wheel is obviously already dead but
there's still a girl like in the back
and she's still alive and she's like
holy [ __ ] like get me out of here so
he's actually able to rescue her and
takes her to the hospital now once he
gets to the hospital he finds out that
the girl that he rescued sally
like she's gonna be okay but the guy
that was driving the car was this real
big muckety-muck governor who was
actually just going to announce his
candidacy for president
and uh so he goes back and he's
listening to the sounds that he recorded
like later on and he's like immediately
when he's at the hospital he's already
getting some blow back from the cops
they're like oh do you know who that is
and he's just like i don't know a dead
guy and he's just like oh it's that
governor or whatever the hell his name
was and he's like oh [ __ ] you know
that's that's something and he tells the
cops he's like i'm pretty sure like i
heard something before the tire blew out
like i heard something that maybe
sounded like a gunshot so i don't know
if it was an accident they're like no no
it's just an accident it's fine and then
they're telling him hey can you just
like conveniently forget that that woman
was in the car because she is you know
like a prostitute or whatever i mean
she's not exactly that like as you find
out later but um they're like and we
don't really want his family to think
that he was like getting a hand job or
whatever the hell was going on like
during the accident
um so can you just like forget and he's
just like yeah but she was in the car
like that's the truth so why he's like
yeah but we don't want to upset his wife
blah blah blah he didn't get it uh yeah
well yeah so he was just kind of like
all right whatever and like i said him
and um
and sally they kind of like strike up a
friendship now when he's listening back
to the recording that he made he is
absolutely positive
that he's like i can hear the tire
blowing out but he's like before that
there was a gunshot he's like and i'm
sure that was a gunshot i'm a sound guy
i hear gunshots you know what i mean
yeah and then the reenactment the shot
composition with him listening and the
tire going by
for the early 80s you know before cg
it was it was quite of a quite a cool
effect
this has so many great shots in it right
and it makes me wonder how much it costs
to get to get them to do that how much
it cost the problem to do that or how
did he even come up with that idea i
mean they were doing split screen stuff
but it wasn't really split screen
it looked like
one image kinda laid over and
superimposed on another one and they
were in different levels
it looked like
it was it was like a decades ahead maybe
a decade ahead of what you would
normally see you didn't see that kind of
[ __ ] yeah it's almost like a collage
it's like a compositional
moving collage i think there's a word
for that but i can't remember what it is
at the moment yeah i don't remember
seeing that until the 90s
yeah that's true yeah where like his
face is like way up in the foreground
and then in the background there's like
layers of like stuff that's going on in
his head right um but yeah and well
the cool thing about it is that he
doesn't really use those kind of shots
or like the split screen composition
just as like showing off or hey look how
neat this looks which it does but part
of the storytelling yeah he also uses it
as a storytelling device because he's
like giving you because there's a really
great shot near the beginning of this
where they establish who the governor
dude is like before he gets killed and
they do it in a split screen
because you have to know who the guy is
because he's like important to the plot
but it would be like really boring just
to have somebody like telling you about
it so there's just like a split screen
where there's like a tv like with a news
thing like kind of talking about him a
little bit and then like in the other
side of the split screen you have john
travolta like doing like with his analog
uh sound recording equipment and
everything him like writing names on
tapes so it's just like a real it's a
good way of like keeping visual interest
and also having like exposition
but it also has interesting stuff going
on so you're not like yeah there's
something about it almost kind of like a
moving storyboard thing out of a comment
yeah it is kind of like imagine you had
a storyboard of a comic book moving but
there's no borders between them that's
merged into the same image it was a
great effect
i didn't really see stuff like that
until later 90s
yeah it's like now that you said i'm
sure somebody can like think of maybe an
earlier example but i do kind of feel
well i think that the reason a lot of
people like diploma so much is because
of these visual stylistic
you know choice and i and i think you
know i think a while back before you
know people really got appreciation for
him they said oh he's just like a
hitchcock he's just ripping off
hitchcock or whatever which he did take
a lot of things from hitchcock but he's
got his own thing going on i mean he's
really got his own like style going on
yeah definitely but um actually one of
the shots and i don't know if you were
awake during this but one of the shots
that a lot of people talk about in this
movie is that there's a point where
uh
jack he realizes that you know the tape
that he made like the recording that he
made in the gunshot and all this other
stuff and all of his other tapes like in
his library have all been erased
and there's a great shot where the the
camera it just like goes 360 like around
the room around the room and it's not
focused on him he's just like running
around going oh [ __ ] and he's like
running out the door over there and he's
like going through this [ __ ] over here
and pulling everything off and then the
camera is just kind of like spinning
around and around the room like not fast
but it's just it really really like ups
the tension and it's kind of like
mirroring his panic at like discovering
that all of his [ __ ] has been erased and
now he doesn't have any proof anymore
and it's just like a really really great
shot i feel like that's the one that a
lot of people bring up yeah no no
digital it's all practical analog
effects yeah this was 81. yeah this was
81. so yeah so as it turns out um so he
made the audio recording obviously of
the gunshot and he's like i'm convinced
that it's a gunshot so that wasn't an
accident it was an assassination because
the the guy did die
so he's trying to like get this
you know out to the public or whatever
and then it turns out that dennis
franz's character who's kind of like a
sleaze bag and you also find out later
he's like associated with nancy allen's
character uh sally
he was actually at the bridge and he
took
film
of the accident and he sold it to
a magazine and the magazine printed it
like frame by frame so basically what
john travolta does is he cuts out all
the pictures and then he make then he
shoots them all and he makes like a film
and he matches it up
with his
sound that he recorded
and when he shows the whole thing back
you can very clearly see that there's
like a gunshot like coming from the
bushes like near where the car is so
he's basically trying to like go to the
press and he's trying to go to the cops
and it's like nobody wants to hear it
and there comes a point too where him
both him and sally are
you know obviously going to be in danger
because
this is an assassination attempt and
they wanted it to look like an accident
so
the fact that he knows about it and that
he won't shut up about it means that
he's gonna be kind of in the crosshairs
so you also have john lithgow's
character who
is kind of like he's not really a serial
killer i guess he's more like well i
mean technically there's a serial killer
but he's kind of like i guess they
become like a fixer like he was the guy
that was supposed to be doing all this
[ __ ] like in the background and so
once john travolta
character and nancy allen's character
like start being troublemakers and it's
clear that they're not gonna like shut
up about this whole assassination thing
then he's kind of like he's like well i
need to step in and he's a political
operative
he's a guy that you hire to [ __ ] take
care of [ __ ] and to [ __ ] frame people
and [ __ ] uh
he's yeah great in this yeah yeah and he
ends up killing like a bunch of other
people too like to make it look like
because he's like well i gotta kill
you know nancy allen at some point so
he's like i'm gonna kill all these other
people like in a real serial killery
kind of way yeah so it'll look random
you know dudes like this actually exist
they come out of the military and then
they become police and they go become
private investigators then they work for
security firms they do this booking
weird [ __ ] yeah trainers training and
everything there's teams some of them
are propagandists and then they've got
other guys who know everything about
forensics and they know
that's how they suicide people and
douche and it's not just here it's
that's this is a global phenomenon
governments use these guys and political
parties use them
yeah and so like i said this movie in a
lot of ways it's a thriller and it kind
of has uh it has like a big time like a
giallo influence to it like especially
in the visuals and in there's kind of
like a little bit of a murder mystery
type of thing going on but it also
homages a lot of the 70s like political
conspiracy type theories uh you know or
movies rather where you know like what
was the one that we did not all the
presidents like all the president's men
and like uh
one three days of the condor
when they were they faked going to the
moon yeah that was a good one
that was a good one capricorn won yeah
yeah yeah jay was in it yeah well
because in the 70s like after watergate
particularly like you and vietnam that
whole debacle so
yeah because all those assassinations
happened in the 60s and then like i said
water so people really i mean in the 70s
there was a million of those kind of
like questions
the reality that's fed to them now
they're going like wait a minute hold on
are the institutions are they tell us
the truth no
and well what's interesting about this
movie though is that it has
it has kind of like that dna in it of
like the political conspiracy theory
like you know movie but
it also has but it also has like a
thriller yeah type like it's because
it's told from the point of view of just
the average joe having to go through it
so yeah and his eye view of it yeah he
just happened to be there like when the
[ __ ] happened and he just happened to be
the kind of person that it's like hey
i'm not going to shut up about this
because it's the truth drawing a
parallel between this and and and three
days of the condor or is it five days or
three days the book is five days the
kind i thought it was three days three
days to come yeah robert redford you're
drawing a parallel yeah it's a lot like
that isn't it yeah it's a lot like that
well there was a lot of these kind of
movies like i said it was a lot of these
kind of movies like in the 70s yeah and
condor is one of the best spy movies
that's that's
like an american james bond type movie
but even but better more realistic uh
i'm gonna give it a shout out right now
go check out [ __ ] three days of the
condor yeah we
reviewed that one a couple of months
back i feel like but yeah i mean if you
like 70s uh political conspiracy
thrillers yeah um but you also like
giallo style murder mystery thrillers
then this is kind of like a good
amalgamation of those two things
and i kind of feel like too
i'm not i don't want to spoil the end
but i will say that man does this thing
have a bummer ending
it is a bomber bomber ending and i had
forgotten
about because like i said i remembered
like the first act of the movie and i
kind of remembered a little bit of the
plot and like some of the scenes but i
didn't remember what happened at the end
so like when i was watching it last
night i was like [ __ ] man that was
[ __ ] up
it is like you said it is the movie's
1981 but his dna is more 70s and a lot
of those movies from the 70s had
ambiguous endings like bullet
another good one
bullet the ending of bullet was you know
the good guys really didn't win they
made it but not really
it's it's that kind of stuff yeah so i
guess this is kind of right in line yeah
same thing with three days of the condor
yeah they made it to the [ __ ] new
york times
but can you trust in new york but now
well and well now what it's like is
anything gonna come about right right
it's something like that the thing about
this movie too is that what i was gonna
say it's like not only like a political
conspiracy thing but
it's also a little bit of a meta
commentary on movie making itself you
know what i mean and i think that's why
he kind of like made the little joke of
like opening it with like hey here's
this cheesy b horror movie and then
three or four minutes later pulling back
and being like just kidding we're
actually doing the serious movie but i
think that
there's a lot the theme of this movie a
lot is kind of like
can you
like at what point is a movie like
real and you know you know what i mean
it's just kind of like i don't know it's
kind of hard for me to like uh
articulate
but
he's so insistent that this is the real
thing but it's like everybody is
basically like [ __ ] on because all
of the all of the evidence that he has
like they're erasing it like they're
getting rid of like they erase his tapes
and they steal his [ __ ] and it's just
like they're trying to discredit him
um but he's just like so it's almost
kind of like making a comment on what's
the line between truth and unreality
like even in the movies or even like in
real life so i think it's almost kind of
like a meta yeah i met a kind of
statement in that way too which i think
i mean de palma did that like a lot in
his movies i feel like there was
something about this movie though it
kind of reminded me what what's that
director that you really like that did
lost highway um david lynch almost kind
of like david lynch mixed with
spielberg almost
kind of had a weird that's good now
david because he had maybe that's not a
there's just a certain feel that i got
with it because spielberg always had a
very mainstream feel to me
and then lynch was totally off the
[ __ ] wall and this was kind of had
elements of both it was a very
mainstream accessible movie but it kind
of had the artistic qualities of lynch
in a way with those weird screenshots
and the good angles
i just i think lynch goes overboard
though
well his stuff like i said he's very
much uh into like images of the
subconscious and like nightmares and
things like that it almost kind of
reminded me of oliver stone he kind of
felt like an oliver stone movie too yeah
a little messier a little flashier
good movie i want to see it again
because i missed a lot of the plot part
but the quality part of it
i got a good idea that this is a very
good quality movie i was getting really
getting into it and i just [ __ ]
pulled off into sleep land and i came
back i missed it and then i saw the end
part it was like oh that's pretty cool
and the the end did look like something
right out of three days of condor now
you talk about it more stylish
but uh yeah this is that kind of movie i
mean this has got style for days pretty
much every all the shot compositions are
really creative but not in a showy yeah
like i said
lynch does it but it's almost he almost
over does it but he has to because he's
trying to trip you out and he's trying
to [ __ ]
tell something to tell something almost
kind of metaphysical or symbolic this is
more grounded in reality than lynch
but
it almost it had a real good feel to it
it just like it's very jealous in the
shock compositions and in the lighting i
really really like yeah it's very
colorful like there's like red lights
and green lights and neon
and stuff like that and i really did
like to um
a lot of the close-ups that he had
always i don't want to go so far as to
say like it fetishizes
the um the machinery like the sound
machinery
it kind of was though like these really
like loving close-ups of them with these
pretty red lights on them everything
looked important
yeah and i looked important and iconic
even the front of that car when they
were in in the hotel in the front of the
hotel room that they read it was all
glass
they got they got him with that sound
equipment and then off to his left is
the front end of his car that big old
[ __ ] grill remember that yeah even
that looked like
like it was important you know like
everything is epic it just it's just
really good everything in this looks
real good shot composition there's a
another movie that visually
it keeps coming to my mind
i can't remember what the name was but
it just has that good like you said real
colorful
contrasting textures like chrome up
against
the dam
tiles you know what i mean you have the
tiles from the inside of the you just
got to see it yeah tiles inside the the
hotel room and then that chrome bumper
that with that grille
is he's just trying to get as much
optical
cool [ __ ] into the shot as possible and
look and it's just right it's good real
good yeah and so you know like i said
you have the whole like political
conspiracy thing you also have a little
bit of a serial killer murder mystery
type thing with the fixer guy john
lithgow and you know you also have a
little bit
i guess because they kind of give like
john travolta like his character's
backstory a little bit about how he used
to work for the police and he used to
wire guys because he was like a sound
person and how that kind of so it's
almost like a little mini crime film
like in there as well like with his
backstory yeah i like the fact that he
included his backstory that he had a
military and police background but in
the support units he was not a hands-on
guy yeah
so that's good because now his character
does have an understanding a situational
understanding what's going on he does
have a chance to get this [ __ ] done you
know because he's at least aware of what
happens yeah so he's not a total fish
out of water but partially yeah which is
the same in three days in the condor
that guy was writing or reading spy
novels and putting all the ideas into a
database that spy agencies were using so
when they came after him he kind of had
the source material he wasn't a spy yeah
he had just read a lot he just read all
the spots right yeah i just read all the
spy novels but he wasn't a spy he didn't
physically have the skills but he was
able to execute yeah for the first time
which yeah i mean like yeah like you
said it's kind of like this where he's
like an every man in every man but he
does have like relevant experience and
he's like really smart and he like
figures [ __ ] out that's why he said that
he uh he was in the military you know
and he was also in police in the support
unit because they said you she was
you're a cop because no not really i was
just part of a commission that you know
and so he knew police procedural yeah
been around there he was the guy that
helped him like you know wire people and
stuff like that when they were trying to
like get audio so he's not just some
nobody who has no knowledge or
experience just pulling out of his ass
they have characters like that in the
movies and they're not believable this
guy's believable because at least he
knows about it yeah you know and then he
just kind of
you know through no fault of his own he
just randomly gets randomly situated in
this assassination plot and then like
his ass is on the line and sally's ass
so you know
conceptually or theoretically he does
have a chance of pulling this off yeah
when an average person wouldn't they
wouldn't even know the basics they would
yeah they wouldn't even be able to
understand what was happening
it was oh it's not assassination bye i'm
good
that's what the average person or even
if they did know like as soon as
somebody said hey uh let's not talk
about that yeah i'd be like yes sir
[Laughter]
like i don't want to get shot he wanted
to stand up for what was right yeah like
a fool
but well he was that was just his that
was just his character and they kind of
established that it's like well that's
not what happened so why should i shut
up about it yeah um and like one take
the hint and i guess he started to like
sally as well and they were just trying
to help her yeah and he was trying to
help her out too so they kind of look
like both got into danger but yeah i
mean if you really like brian de palma's
other movies and you maybe haven't seen
this one because like i said i feel like
this one gets a little bit
swept under not swept under the rug but
it just gets forgotten about like in the
context of like all his other films i
suppose but this is like way way better
than i remembered because i hadn't seen
it for probably like 20 or 30 years and
it's just really really good and i think
it's easily one of his best thrillers
one of john travolta's best roles one of
john travolta's best roles easily
probably maybe maybe the best although
you know what i mean you know greece was
iconic but he's mostly musical role as
far as acting this is from what i saw i
didn't get to see all of it but this was
like his best work yeah because this is
a very it's a dramatic role and there's
not really any humor or anything like
that and he's real credible and he's
great he's great in it um everybody's
great in this i just it's it's an
all-star cast and it's just like i said
it's a great looking movie it's just it
sucks you right in like the story sucks
you right in and it's just great it's
great and you know and i had forgotten
how great it was so if you have hbo max
uh you can watch it on there for free or
i'm sure it's probably streaming
somewhere else i believe criterion also
released uh you know a release but like
a special edition of it maybe last year
or early this year and the cover of it
looks really nice so you know you can go
that route if you have the money uh
because i heard there was like a lot of
really cool special features on there
but uh yeah if you've seen it let us
know what you thought about it in the
comments what's your favorite bryant de
palma movie stuff like that and we will
see you guys again on the next
retrospective bye